a disney executive producer named latoya
ravenous has found her own way into the
club and uh it's pretty interesting
listen to this
i identify as like a biromantic asexual
i've had a lot
of
learning and growing about myself this
year kind of facilitated by how
comfortable i felt on
the proud family and with my immediate
team at disney tva and so it's just sort
of like
this creative dissonance between my
personal experience
a biromantic asexual
now let's break this down
an asexual is somebody who supposedly
doesn't experience any sexual attraction
at all to anyone the problem with that
identification is that first of all if
it's true that somebody experiences no
sexual attraction at all then it makes
absolutely no sense to include them in
the lgbt community given that this is a
community which is literally defined by
its various sexual attractions
putting an asexual person in the lgbt
camp it's like it's like having a club
for club for bird watchers and also
including people who have absolutely no
interest in bird watching
these are people who do not want to
partake in the very thing
that defines the club
it makes no sense to have them in the
club in that case
also
people are not meant to be asexual and
are not asexual
now some animal species are asexual like
komodo dragons and certain species of
crayfish but people are not komodo
dragons or crayfish
that woman as far as i can tell is
neither of those things she's a human
being
what we call asexuality would more
properly be characterized as a low
libido or a disinterest in romantic
relationships that's not the same thing
scientifically as asexuality
it is rather a dysfunction of the brain
which may be due to hormonal problems or
some sort of mental illness or trauma
suffered earlier in life you know it
could be a lot of reasons or perhaps i
think this is the most common it could
also be a symptom of spiritual despair
some people have given up on human
relationships because they've decided
that they're not worth the cost or the
effort
but that's not asexuality
and and whatever the cause of this
affliction it's not an identity
it's bizarre and self-limiting to find
your whole identity and your sexual
attraction but it's even more bizarre
and far more limiting to find your
identity in your lack of attraction
you are finding your sense your sent
yourself your sense of self
in the absence of something
this is no way to become a fully formed
and stable human being
but wait a second
she says that she's not only asexual but
also biromantic
well what does that mean
i mean in reality romantic means
something that is characterized by love
and affection towards another person
this is the dictionary definition
and we have to understand love in this
in this context
to be the erotic form of love
that's what romantic love is
that's why you would hopefully say that
you love your mother but you would even
more hopefully not say that you go you
go out to dinner with your mother it's a
romantic dinner
see there are different kinds of love
and romantic love is erotic love it's
sexual love
these are these are the same erotic
sexual romantic these are all synonyms
they belong in the same category
so how can somebody be romantic
more than that biromantic meaning that
they have romantic attraction to both
sexes and yet also at the same time be
asexual
well they can't is the answer
one of the latest lgbt innovations is to
draw this incoherent bifurcating line
between romantic and sexual but the
distinction just like the distinction
between sex and gender is meaningless
romantic and sexual are the same thing
they are characterized the same way
if you're not romantically attracted to
somebody then you're not sexually
attracted to them if you are
romantically attracted to them you're
sexually attracted to them
there is no legible distinction between
the two
and yet the lgbt activists
draw one anyway
this is their game it never ends they
never stop their assault on language and
logic
all coherent concepts have to be broken
down
torn to shreds
blended together and turned into a
jumbled smoothie of meaningless
contradictions
and that's why ultimately today we
thought i was going to cancel disney but
we already cancelled them so instead
in a much more specific sense we are
canceling biromantic asexuals can't
really be canceled i guess because they
don't exist but even so
casel well i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the matt wall show if you did go
ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content